a week in the life of the beautiful game
over five days a run of pitch invasions
and occasional violence
the latest a confrontation between
crystal palace manager patrick vieira
and an everton fan seen taunting him
before the former arsenal midfielder
kicks out
this footage was posted on social media
filmed by the fan
supporters also stormed the pitch at
swindon after port vale beat the club in
a league two playoff semi-final
swindon player mandela egbo tweeted this
photo showing a cut to his nose
but this was undoubtedly the worst
incident of the week a nottingham forest
fan now in prison headbutts sheffield
united's billy sharp i think we're
we're going into dangerous territory
where
something could happen in a game that
has terrible consequences and i don't
think anyone would want to see that so i
think the authorities have to act
quickly to make sure we make the grounds
as safe as we can
disorders on the rise up 36
fans are embarrassed
depressing
and upsetting to be honest um the
spoiling bit was fun
stopping the match
they're putting people at risk we
shouldn't be doing anything which
involves criminality i don't think we
should be doing anything which brings
our club into distribute at brentford
football club more security is in place
ahead of sunday's match with leeds one
of the directors also chair of the
supporters trust says it's tricky to
find the right deterrence
you can see why you know a lifetime ban
is a real disincentive like
to bad behavior but what really matters
i think can we somehow get fans who are
badly behaved to change their ways that
that would be the best way but how best
to do that that's what we're still
trying to find out the fa is
investigating and says it will be
seeking to do all that it can to work
with clubs as well as addressing the
issues from a disciplinary perspective
we're also reviewing our regulations it
adds to help stamp this behavior out and
to ensure the safety of everyone inside
a stadium there's a certain element of
copycat behavior there's also a certain
impact in terms of social media
but ultimately this is still post lock
down excitement
[Applause]
the football league's looking at new
ideas including cutting stadium capacity
another attempt to try and end this ugly
side of the beautiful game adele
robinson sky news